Hello everybody, welcome to another zoom call. This is
recorded after the zoom call because the recording didn't
record of the zoom call
Wonderful. So I'm very recording this. I will not have the questions
That were asked on the chat. So apologize for that because they weren't saved
So we got to figure out a different way to record the zoom calls because over zoom it seems to mess up about once a month
And that's a little bit of a hassle. So I'm gonna figure out another way that we can double record it somehow so we don't lose that zoom call
All right, let's get started. So just a reminder again. You have a question go to our regular website and search for it
We do not have a search bar in the members only site in the membership site. There's no search bar
We will be working on trying to get that written, but it doesn't exist right now
But go to our regular website and search for it and they have already created a video on the question that you have
And speaking of the membership site if you are not on the membership site
Well, you're probably not watching this video. So
We don't really need to talk about that right now
but
This is how you would get on it by asking to
Get an invite everybody should have got it invite by now. So
All right, let's get to some of the questions
This one I heard a lot of people especially seniors and others with kidney problems
My issue have been injured by contrast dies and
And so
This is a question about contrast dies and
How they can be unhealthy for you. So we're talking about contrast dies for MRI and CT scans
Can a patient do other detoxes like OZ old or vitamin C IV or charcoal or something else right after
The test to expedite the detoxification of the contrast die
Well, I wouldn't choose OZ old to that detox
Anything OZ will help kill biotoxins it won't help detox
pesticide or
Contrast dye or heavy metal or it's like that. OZ is not a detoxification tool
Vitamin C does help with some things that can be beneficial, but it's certainly not a key later
But you want is something that will key late that out
We use a wholeopathic key later, but you could use other keylators as well
But the biggest thing is to support your liver make sure you do it coffee enemas make sure you're doing
Castoral packs over your liver prior to this
doing receiving a dye and after receiving a contrast dye
Especially if you have any sensitivities to it make sure that you
Look at that and
Then when doing coffee enemas how much of the liquid is an appropriate amount?
I read recently that more than two cups can stretch the bowel and if coffee goes too far
It could be a strip electrolytes before they get a chance to be ribs or back in the body
Well, you don't think any of this is true. So
More than two cups stretch the bowel. You have 30 feet of bowel. So
That just doesn't make any sense. I don't know where that was written
So whatever whoever wrote that I am just in total disagreement of that. You can't stretch the bowel
You know with by doing coffee enemas
Or any sort of enemas. That doesn't make even make any physiological sense and it won't go up very high
So an enemas not gonna go up very high you have normal
Parastaltic waves that push fluid
Out so you're not gonna be able to get an enemagoid really beyond too much beyond the
Upper rectum. So and you really don't need it to so no matter how much you put in you won't
It's certainly you're not gonna strip electrolytes. So I just totally disagree with that
But you don't really only need two cups and I've always said over and over again
I say that don't get hung up on how much
coffee you're getting in
Year by all every time you do a coffee enemas some people get discouraged
I could only get a little bit in and had to go right away
I couldn't hold it more than 30 seconds or two minutes or one of my doing wrong
Don't you're not doing anything around just keep doing it. You're doing fine
Don't get discouraged if you're having trouble with a coffee enemma. You're not getting enough in
You're not holding it long enough. Just keep doing it the purpose of a coffee enemagoid is to stimulate your parasympathetics
It's not to
Accomplish a task of holding it for 15 minutes and lay it on one side and flip it to the other side and
Doing any of those things. It's just to stimulate the parasympathetics in the in the
rectal area. So
Next question. I got a massage yesterday afternoon after word I had a healthy involvement
Then I did my daily coffee enemma which I could hold for only about seven minutes
This never happens. I always hold the entire 15 minutes
It's might have doing warm up water enemma which I also could not hold
Then a few hours later had another healthy involvement. Could all this extra bowl activity be related to the massage?
The other Herk's reactions experience were might or joint pain and slightly lower
Energy for the remainder of the day crashing a few hours earlier than normal. I'm wondering if I could be
More intentional about getting massage as if they're this effective for me and help you remove toxins
Good observation when you get a massage and you haven't had a massage for a long time
You can flush a lot of toxins out of the muscles and extra
Cellular spaces and the fascia layer and center of your body where you have a lot of inflammation and you can end up with a
Herk'simer reaction what this person is talking about a herk'simer reaction is a reaction when you're basically kind of
Overloaded your detox pathways. You just feel cruddy the rest of the day
Some people don't like to get a massage because they don't get them very often
And they feel good during the massage, but then they feel cruddy for two days afterwards
So the treatment for that is to get a massage more regularly so you can get your tissues more flushed out
The other part of this question is could all this extra bowl activity be related to the massage? I'd say
Absolutely for sure
So when you get a massage, it's very relaxing and very comforting that stimulates your parasympathetics and your parasympathetics like I said the last slide
Our what stimulates your parastaltic activities
Parastalsis in the gut is the movement contraction of the muscles around the intestinal track that move
Your feces through your gut. That's what you want. That's a function of your parasympathetic nervous system
And another reason why you do coffee animals
Course to stimulate your parasympathetics and one thing that does is it moves your bowel. So
Good observation. Yeah, I would say good idea to get a massage more regularly
X question the tuber site on the ankle has gotten really painful enlarged
Once she started I am bat foot baths
She had done it every day for the first four days and it hasn't done one for three days now
The site is gone down and it's not painful
Is that a normal reaction would you see the foot bath too much sure
Uh, do you think this is something else going on?
I guess we're not sure what type of reaction at the tumor sites is normal
I wouldn't say this is normal. I'd say there's something going on. I'd like to see a picture of the tumor site and see
Uh, the reaction that that is happening
One sense it could be actually good
Um, another sense that it could just be irritation and some fluid there
So I don't want to see a picture of that we should have a chat
I don't know who asked this question. So maybe follow up with me send me a picture and we should have a chat
X question can high dose Boswellia so Boswellia is an anti-inflammatory
Technically a flavonoid that can reduce inflammation. It would be used
To reduce inflammation in the brain. It can be reduced inflammation in the tissues. It's really good for inflammation in the gut
So this versus taken 4,200 milligrams a day. That's very high dose
Boswellia
Can it lower platelet count? Is that that's the question? Well anything that's going to be an anti-inflammatory
Taking a really high dose could lower your platelet counts
Yes, because it is going to make your blood
Less viscous. It's going to make your blood. It's going to thin your blood a little bit
So I had to go off chemo for a week due to low platelet count
No, I'm back on chemo again. However, I would like to take the high dose Boswellia again
Due to its great benefits for associated with glioblastoma and stem cell apoptosis
I want to redo I want to take it to reduce some minor inflammation as well
That I have outside the tumor resection site
I would say just to go back on it again and maybe prior to chemo maybe drop your dosage down or don't take it for three days prior to chemo
See what your platelet count is
So that you can still get your chemo if that's what you're desiring
So I would try to reduce that dosage around the chemo then you could
You could wrap it back up again
On one of the rife videos you talk about stopping cancer
Tuber growth via rife which is a big win
You mentioned that it doesn't matter if the body seals
Away a tumor as it's no longer cancer
So in one of the videos I talk about is that uncertain cancers that tumors can just get walled off
That's common with lung cancer. It's coming with brain cancer. It's coming with breast cancer
It's coming with liver cancer and some pancreatic cancers that as you're as the body just
As it stops
Replicated your body doesn't necessarily always clean it up and make it go away
Your body can just wall it off
Especially in those cancers that I just mentioned and I said in this video
I believe something to the like that that's okay
Just leave it just don't do anything with it. It's not hurting you just leave it alone. It's stopped replicating
That's really what we want
But the continuation of this question is is I'm thinking in the case of colon cancer if the tumor is actually obstructing the colon
We don't want to just wall it off
We wanted to reduce size or be gone
Well usually that's what does happen with colon cancer so I don't think we need to be concerned about it
Typically it don't get so much of a wall off with colon cancer
One of their non-surgical methods can you do to reduce the
Such address the situation. I'd say just keep on the course and let's see what happens to the tumor
My husband has acute myeloid leukemia. My son has great to glioma
Is there a test for the other five members of the family to take to see if we are also at risk?
How do we get that done?
So you have two members of the family with two different cancers
You do have to scratch your head and go huh?
What is going on here?
so
number one there's not a genetic link here
There's no genetic link to aml no or to glioma so let's cross that off
But there's a different sweet genetics and familial so familial link would be everybody in the family is eating the same food
Everybody in the family is exposed to the same house hold mold maybe
Everybody in the family is living in the same house and the same neighborhood
Where there's a high degree of toxicity in the water or in the environment
So you got to look at environmental things. I would also kind of do some investigation in the neighborhood
If you live in a city on
How many other people within a x amount of block radius have been diagnosed with cancer?
Is it higher than normal in the state's average?
I don't know how you do all that investigation, but there's some things you could look up. There's a
there's a
website called scorecard
SCORE
C-A-R-D
Um, and that is a website which lists the
toxicity
levels of your
neighborhood via zip code so you'd put it in your zip code five five
oh eight two and it will list the number one pollutant polluters
Company-wise in your area and the number one pollutants
What chemicals are the number one pollutants in your zip code area?
This is all because of the environmental pollutionation to see
Requires companies that emit pollutants to list the types of chemicals that are
They're polluting because they have to stay below a certain limit, but these things add up
um, so that's one way to look at it
um, I know in our neighborhood in our neck of the woods in Minnesota
There three M company had years ago in the 60s and 70s and 80s had paid farmers a hundred dollars
to bury barrels of
very very toxic substances in their field say that they won't leach out and we'll give you a hundred
dollars to bury this and they said yes and they buried
hundreds of barrels of toxins
in various fields
around Lake Elbow and Oakdale and Cottage Grove area in Minnesota
well those have leaked out into the water polluting
large municipalities of water supplies
Causing these municipalities to get very very costly filters etc
3M was sued over this
But damage was done and damage is still being done if you have well water and you could be in your in that aquifer
You could have issues
I know in uh by
Office that I used to have years ago in stillwater
Right near that office within a five block area the incidents of cancer
Were through the roof and nobody ever figured it out that I know of I don't know if it was some
EMF
This is before really cell phones were big if I have no idea what it was
They're all of the still water water system
But it was just this five block radius where incidents of cancer was really really high
So some things are very very difficult to figure out some things you can put your figure on it
What I had a patient once that he's he did not have cancer
He came to me for an autoimmune disease and he lived on a potato farm and he was like third generation potato farmer
And I said um, so what's it like on a potato farm?
He said well, I actually moved off when I was 20 and he was in his 40s now
He said my dad made me move away because literally
No one in our family
But all my aunts and uncles and cousins all developed cancer before 50
And my dad swears it's because all the pesticides that you have to use
To spray for potato bugs
Um
Potatoes you know are one of the dirty dozen list of your foods and one thing that
Probably the most one of the most sprayed vegetables there are
Because potato bugs don't die easy and you have to spray them directly in order to kill them
And they come back like crazy if you've ever grown potatoes
So in my potato garden, I'm down picking potato bugs every few days and killing them because we don't use any
pesticides
So they're kind of fun to pick and squash
If you have gloves on
If you get into that kind of thing, but you have to pick your potato bugs or they could literally just literally eat all your potato leaves off of your
Potatoes and you won't be able to get energy for the growing tumors underneath
So growing organically is difficult and um, it takes a lot more effort
So
Back to this question
The exposure that you may have familial you're going to have to do some investigation
could be completely
you know
Something you'd never be able to figure out it could be something that you might be able to put your figure on
But do a little bit of private investigation into the next question
Energy highs and lows are concerning
One week he is out
This person is talking with their husband one week. He's out
Using a chainsaw and doing work the next week is energy is very low
When should we be concerned? Well
You should be concerned. Can you do anything about it? That's the question
Um, and it really has to do with how low are the lows and are the highs the days that he's feeling good
Working with his chainsaw is he more and more sluggish even doing that
Um should set up a time that we could talk about this
Because if you're noticing that trained, you know, it's it's the lows are not good when your energy's low
But then when you get your energy back and you're doing well
That's a really a good sign. So if he's having these highs and lows
That's a much better sign than just cuts and lows obviously
Uh, and then watch how low those lows are getting so maybe set up a time that we can talk
For my non-smell small cell lung cancer, the oncologist offers a critical trial that includes a maston
By understanding that that a maston shuts down the capillary
Formation at the tumor to private it of its nutrients
Is there a non-drug alternative? One that also suppresses capillary formation
Well, um, I don't know all the um
Mechanisms of action of a vast and with small non-smell cell lung cancer
Have the studies that are showing that it's been official for that
But yes, I do agree that you don't want to increase
Uh, veg F formation which is vascular endothelial growth factor
Um, so the things that you would do for a natural standpoint to reduce
The veg F
That vascular growth factor is to avoid
Nutrients that contain high amounts of nitric oxide
So remember a lot of things that you do for cancer are the exact opposite of what you would do for heart disease
So if you have heart disease
coronary artery disease or some blockage
High blood pressure you want to increase nitric oxide production
So there's a lot of supplements on the market for that
also for
for um
erectile dysfunction same thing you want to increase nitric oxide production because that increases the
vascular endothelial growth factor who will increase the growth of new vessels
You literally could grow new vessels in your heart and bypass naturally
growing new vessels bypass blocked arteries
Um, and it increases the size of the little bit of the vessel
So it will decrease blood pressure
So nitric oxide is a great supplement for that
But nitric oxide isn't such a great supplement for a person with cancer because
nitric oxide increases growth of new blood vessels
And when you have a
solid tumor like
Like a small cell lung cancer or breast cancer or colon cancer etc not a blood cancer
But what do you have a hard tumor solid tumor you don't want to increase vascularization into the tumor because
Then it's basically giving the tumor
new highways for food
Sources and so you want to stay away from nitric oxide supplements. Oh, that's why we don't use those with cancer patients
Um, but that's why I also write that you don't want to be making kale shakes
Well, you have a cancer
You can have a little kale in your salad. That's just fine
But you don't make a blend up a kale shake like you may hear about with people with heart issues or trying into aging properties
um kale has the highest amount of nitric oxide
Of any vegetable
About four times as high as spinach. So
You would want to avoid making this doing something like that
Uh, eGcg from green t-extra can help decrease bedjef
That would be one natural solution for this as well
Other than castoral packs. I don't see any liver support on the protocol
Maybe the castoral packs are enough. I get the impression his liver this person's talking about their child
His liver is taxed. He does one castoral pack per day
I've done them twice per day on occasion. He gets very angry sometimes
This used to happen after I gave him the adics adics is a holiopath
Key later for
Uh, different toxins
I started only giving him adics when he was on a castoral pack and that helped
I only give him a partial spray of adics now and that helps too
It seems like the castoral packs are having less effectiveness on his anger
So yes, you do want to support the liver detox pathways, but you want to keep an eye on
Everything downstream. So remember go back to that
Seven phases of detox and we're talking with liver as phase one and two and three
Well, you need to support four five six
Also, so make sure you're he's able to empty the liver and that's one of the great things about
Just hot packs even if you won't do castoral just do a hot pack over his liver
He might be much more inclined to
Allow you to do that with him and it could have just a great
Result of just
Helping the bile become less viscous helping motion of the bile helping the liver to be able to drain
And that could be a great thing. Plus remember in your rife programs that I've created. There is liver detoxification
Frequencies as well
Hi Dr. Cutters. Is it normal for my hammer bulb to get super hot while I sleep with it
I try to sleep with it either of my chest or right next to me, but sometimes I need to place it
Back on its stand because it gets too hot
Yes, it does get warm
While you sleep with it, but good news is is that I have created a new version six with different duty cycles for all your
Frequency so everybody with an f122 with an f122
The last three days I shipped out new programs to
everybody that
Was on my list so if you don't get a program
By the end of May and you have an f22 to contact the office
so that um I
Get that created for you so I've been working very diligently on that for the last couple weeks
And um have gotten very little sleep, but I want you guys to have the best programs
This is these are gonna be stronger programs and they won't cause the bulb to get so hot
so um
I don't when you get this new flash drive I put some instructions in there with it was
How to put it in your computer?
I put a little half sheet on why I'm giving you this new update
Um, I want you to use the new update
So when you get this put it in your computer and start using these new programs
Okay, so don't call the office and say they're different because they are different. Yes, they're different
And they are shorter beaded that there's that shorter and length for the day
But there's there only one week programs. So I'm changing everybody's to only one week programs
You're not gonna have two weeks or three week programs anymore
You're having one week programs and they're new iron cleanse pro wave programs as well with different duty cycles
use these new ones, please
um, and
Start using them right away. That's gonna help solve this heat problem
And um you just it's gonna be much more powerful and much more beneficial for everybody
So I'm very excited about that. We are constantly constantly
Try to give you the best service possible and to give you the best product possible
I want you to win in this endeavor and
So we're just constantly trying to improve
So um
Thank you for this and I apologize that that didn't get recorded. We're gonna try to
Find a different program to record zoom because zoom. I don't I think it's just because it's so overused that
Sometimes it just doesn't work great
All right, thanks. Bye-bye